Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a Sci-Fi thriller
film called “Blindness.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins with the scene of a young
man on his way to work suddenly going blind
in the middle of a traffic stop.
When the traffic light turns green and the
man is not able to move his car, the cars
behind him begin honking at him repeatedly.
Soon some concerned city dwellers approach
the man and learn that he has lost his vision.
A good samaritan named X offers to drive the
man home and help clear the traffic.
As they head to his apartment, the blind man
describes his sudden affliction as an expanse
of dazzling white as though he is “swimming
in milk”.
Eventually they arrive at the blind man’s
upscale apartment.
However, as soon as the blind man gets out
of his car, the rescuer flees with the blind
man’s vehicle.
Later, the blind man’s wife returns home
and is shocked to learn about her husband’s
condition.
She immediately decides to take him to a local
ophthalmologist.
The doctor performs a thorough examination
of the man’s eyes but fails to find the
reason for his sudden blindness.
For most blind people everything goes dark
but the blind man mentions seeing white.
The doctor refers the man to a hospital.
Meanwhile, the man who stole the blind man’s
car runs into a police check.
Afraid of getting caught, he illegally changes
lanes and abandons the car.
However, before he could get away, the man
gets his karma and suddenly goes blind like
the man who he stole from.
At home, the doctor tells his wife about the
strange illness.
After eating the dinner that she makes for
him, the doctor stays up late to research
the condition.
By the next morning, two more people become
victims of the illness, a local prostitute
who always wears dark glasses and the doctor
himself.
The doctor’s wife tries to examine his eyes
but he pushes her away, afraid of infecting
her with the condition.
However, she refuses his attempts to keep
her at arm's length and promises she will
be safe.
In various locations of the city, several
more citizens are struck blind, causing widespread
panic.
The government takes cognizance of the situation
and prepares a quarantine facility in a local
derelict asylum.
A crew wearing hazmat suits arrives outside
the doctor’s home to pick him up.
Worried about him, the doctor’s wife climbs
into the van with him pretending to be blind
to accompany him into isolation.
The facility has been divided into multiple
wards and each ward must elect a ward captain
to represent them and communicate with the
outside world.
The woman who wears dark glasses, the first
blind man, the car thief, and a young boy
join the doctor in his ward.
The first blind man quickly recognizes the
car thief’s voice and a fight breaks out
between the two.
The doctor breaks them apart and effectively
assumes the role of the ward’s captain.
The doctor’s wife teaches the blind how
to navigate in the corridors.
More blind people join the doctor’s ward
including the first blind man’s wife.
With the number of infected people rapidly
increasing, in a due course of time, more
and more people are crammed into the same
facility, way beyond its capacity.
The overcrowding and neglect from the government
causes the hygiene and living conditions in
the facility to deteriorate rapidly.
The walls and the floors soon become caked
in filth and feces.
People become increasingly hopeless.
Anxiety over the availability of food, caused
by irregular deliveries, undermines the infected
people’s morale.
The soldiers who guard the asylum become increasingly
hostile and the government refuses to allow
in basic medicines, so that a simple infection
becomes deadly.
One day, the doctor’s wife meets an old
man with an eye-patch in the facility.
He lives in another ward but asks to move
to the doctor’s ward.
The old man has a radio so the doctor’s
wife allows him to change wards.
The old man tells the doctor and others in
his ward about the things he knows about the
outside world through the radio.
He tells them that the sudden blindness which
is known as the white sickness has spread
all around the world, with hundreds of cases
being reported everyday.
The governments around the world held countless
seminars and round table talks on the situation
but couldn’t find a solution.
Things quickly went out of control and the
outside world has come to a halt.
One day, while delivering a new batch of infected
people to the facility, a blind man wanders
away from his group and gets mercilessly shot
by the soldiers.
Panic ensues and two other people get killed
in the resulting stampede.
The next day, the soldiers callously toss
a shovel over the wall that surrounds the
quarantine facility and order the infected
people to bury the corpses of the people killed
the other day.
The doctor proposes that they divide the work
and each ward buries one body.
People of ward 3 are not pleased with the
idea and they refuse to take responsibility
for people they don’t even know.
The doctor clashes with their leader who declares
himself as the king of ward 3.
Over the course of the next few days, the
thief, who is no longer able to walk because
of an infection, finds out the truth about
the doctor’s wife.
He confronts her about it and pleads with
her to help him escape so he could get his
infection treated.
However, the doctor’s wife dismisses him
and tells him that he is wrong about her.
Fed up of waiting for treatment, the thief
attempts to flee the facility that night but
ends up getting shot dead.
The doctor’s wife feels she is responsible
for the thief’s death but the doctor tells
her that she is already doing everything she
can.
When she continues to insist that she should
have come clean about her eyesight, the doctor
gets upset with her and tells her that she
is already acting like everyone’s “mother”
and she doesn’t need to do more.
The king of ward 3 and his men hold everyone
at gunpoint and take control over the food
that the government delivers.
He orders everyone to hand over their valuable
possessions to him in exchange for rations.
The infected reluctantly relinquish their
valuables with which they had sentimental
values attached in exchange for food which
is way less than they used to get before.
Moreover, due to frustration of being unable
to take care of himself and a feeling of helplessness,
the doctor and his wife continue to drift
apart.
After finding the doctor upset, the woman
with the dark glasses comforts him and tries
to cheer him up.
One thing leads to another and the doctor
and the woman end have having sex.
Both immediately regret it even more so when
they realise that the doctor’s wife witnessed
their entire tryst.
The woman apologises to his wife and learns
about her eyesight.
The next day, the King of Ward 3 demands women
in exchange for food.
People refuse to comply and three days pass
by.
The doctor’s wife asks the soldiers outside
for food but they tell her that they have
already received food for the week and the
responsibility of distribution is solely on
the people inside.
Desperate for food, people begin debating
whether they should comply with the ward 3’s
demands.
They ask the doctor for advice.
He tells them that he is in no place to guide
them and asks them to do whatever they feel
like doing.
One by one, the women volunteer to be sex
slaves for the men in the ward 3, and the
King of Ward 3 forces himself on the doctor's
wife.
One of the women is brutally beaten to death
by her tormentor.
The next day, the ward 3 men take the women
of ward 2.
A ward 3 man taunts the doctor’s wife on
his way back, which makes her snap.
She takes a scissor to ward 3 and murders
their leader.
She proudly boasts to the ward 3 men that
they will never be able to know who she is
before walking away with the women.
She tells her husband about the revenge but
he could care less about it.
He is more worried about the possible war.
The people of ward 1 and 2 learn about the
assasinationg of the king of ward 3 and grow
worried about a retaliation.
Meanwhile, they barricade their wall anticipating
a possible war.
The group then discusses giving up the person
who killed the leader of ward 3.
Hearing this, the doctor’s wife almost gives
herself up but she is interrupted by the radio
man, who suggests that they should get the
food back themselves.
In this way, the group plots a plan to fight
back.
One of the girls from ward 1 sneaks into ward
3 and lights a chair on fire.
This gives ward one the opportunity to approach
ward 3 with weapons.
However, the fire has spread to all wards,
and chaos ensues.
Everyone goes outside and the doctor’s wife
calls out to the guards but finds out that
no one is there.
She then finds out that the doors are unlocked
and everyone finally leaves the place.
As they walk around the city, they notice
how far society has fallen and witness the
devastation around them.
Blind people roam the streets and everything
looks grim.
Eventually, the doctor and his wife head out
to salvage supplies.
The doctor tries telling his wife that he
misses her but she remains cold and ignores
his sentiments.
The wife then enters a supermarket but finds
that all the racks are empty and people are
going paranoid with hunger.
She then ventures to the basement and finds
a large stack of food that she hadn't even
dreamt of since ages.
She collects 2 bags of supplies and goes upstairs.
However, the hunger stricken people sense
that she has something and immediately attack
her.
The doctor who was waiting at the door, rushes
to aid her and the couple run away.
After they reach a safe place, the doctor
realizes that he left his clothes behind at
the supermarket so he returns to get them
back.
The tired wife sits and looks on as a pack
of dogs eat a dead man.
Suddenly, a dog comes by and gives her company.
It starts raining so she gets inside and the
dog follows her.
The doctor also arrives with the clothes and
after wearing jackets, they head back to their
place.
Outside, the people enjoy the rain and are
seen rejoicing in the experience, even if
it's for a little while.
The following day, the doctor’s wife takes
the group to their home.
Fortunately, no one had invaded their home
and it looks intact.
She then cleans up the messy place in order
to make everyone feel at home.
There, everyone is seen helping each other
as if they are one big family.
The 3 women later take a shower where they
are laughing and enjoying the experience.
The doctor’s wife describes the women to
them as they haven’t seen themselves in
a long while.
Later that night, the radio man expresses
his happiness on the fact that he has met
a lot of good people during these critical
times.
He also continues by saying that they can
live together like this for a long time.
During dinner, the doctor’s wife cheerfully
describes the items and their locations on
the table and the group has an awkward cheers,
which they laugh at.
That night, the doctor and his wife finally
make love and he explains how much he loves
her.
The following morning, the doctor’s wife
wakes up early and makes her special coffee
for everyone.
Suddenly, the first man starts seeing everything
around him.
Mixed with feelings of shock and joy, he exclaims
that everything is very beautiful.
He then goes around the house, greeting everyone
with happiness.
Everyone is extremely happy at the new revelation,
thinking that it's only a matter of time before
their sight is back as well.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.